[Musik]
das jungfraujoch top of europe
hochalpine gletscher welt im unesco
welterbe
inszenierte kunstwelt in fels und eis
fast dreieinhalb tausend meter über meer
[Applaus]
über eine million besucher im letzten
jahr die meisten aus asien die marke
jungfraujoch verkauft sich gut
trotz tourismuskrise doch gut ist im
hart umkämpften tourismusgeschäft nicht
gut genug mit dreistelligen millionen
investitionen in neue bahnen schnellere
bequemere effizientere soll der profit
weiter gesteigert werden
alles oder nichts es gehe und die
touristische zukunft
[Musik]
doch zu welchem preis
unsere reise aufs jungfraujoch beginnt
unten am dorf rand von grindelwald hier
wohnt und lebt otto kaufmann mit seiner
familie seit 30 jahren sein grundstück
nicht exakt unter dem geplanten einer
express einer ultraschnellen seilbahn
von grindelwald zum eyecatcher
sie soll die reisezeit aufs jungfraujoch
massiv verkürzen und auch die skifahrer
schneller auf den berg bringen und sich
so hängen einzumieten
und da macht sie so karin der clk cabrio
ich habe mich noch nicht vorstellen es
gibt 24
sachs erlangen 11 sekunden 100 kabinen
disco kabine zum weltruhm stahlwelt
sekunde hatte
niemand verletzt
es ist das haus seiner großeltern otto
kaufmann hatte es eigenhändig renoviert
viel geld investiert hier sind seine
kinder groß geworden
mittlerweile sind die kinder ausgeflogen
foto kaufmann lebt mit seiner frau chris
alleine das neue bandprojekt hat ihr
leben total verändert alles nur nicht
das doch wer in grindelwald gegen den
touristischen fortschritt ist hat es
schwer sagt ihr sowohl krach kam der
inklusiv osterferien anderen volk und ja
auch vieles preisgeben
eigentlich wollte ich sehe jetzt doch
nicht sagen dass ich mir doch noch ist
der ärger express nicht gebaut noch
fahren die züge richtung kleine
scheidegg und jungfraujoch wie immer das
dilemma von otto kaufmann er selbst ist
kondukteur bei den jungfraubahnen bei
der firma die in die seilbahn das haus
bauen will
seit 40 jahren verdient er sein geld bei
der bahn jeweils acht monate pro jahr
im sommer ist er auf der alb dass er
gegen die ausbaupläne ist macht ihn zum
außenseiter seinen arbeitgeber zu seinen
größten feind
otto kaufmann hat genug er hat gekündigt
lässt sich frühzeitig pensionieren
es ist sein letzter arbeitstag noch ein
paar hundert jungfraujoch touristen hoch
fahren dann nur noch weg auf die alb wo
er seine ruhe hat
[Musik]
eineinhalb stunden dauert die zugfahrt
bis zum höchstgelegenen bahnhof europas
mit aussicht auf den größten gletscher
europas den aletschgletscher superlative
die sich gut verkaufen
[Musik]
gestern paris heute jungfraujoch morgen
rom für viele asiaten auf europareise
gehört das jungfraujoch zum programm
diese hochalpine wunderwelt mit shops
und attraktionen auf engstem raum
an spitzentagen in der hochsaison mit
5000 besuchern wird der platz in einem
der unterirdischen stollen treffen wir
andreas wies technischer leiter mit
seinen bald dreißig dienstjahren ist er
der dienstälteste mitarbeiter von 120
beschäftigten welche tag für tag den
besucher ansturm bewältigen
180 x 180 solcher im jahr gerechnet und
hätte eigentlich durch it infrastruktur
um etwa ihre themen eigentlich trubel
bewältigen und entsprechend literatur
und beansprucht
[Musik]
eineinhalb bis zwei stunden bleiben die
touristen im durchschnitt auf dem joch
eilen von attraktion zu attraktionen
fasziniert vom gletscher und ewigen
schnee
[Musik]
nach dem fototermin auf der sphinx
geht's weiter zum eispalast das über 200
meter langes labyrinth den gletscher ist
eine der hauptattraktionen auf dem
jungfraujoch aufwendig und kunstvoll
gestaltet doch mit dem touristenansturm
entstehen ganz neue probleme probleme
die es früher nicht gab
er goss oder den geldgierigen norway
jedoch dann wirklich zwischen 100 und
200 wort werde mir ab also das ist ist
es auch zu einer potenziell wo man dank
wegtragen durch zeigte dann keinen
offiziellen charakter wird kann aber mit
technischen maßnahmen aber nicht sondern
wollen wir einfach sich später sie sieht
ihr wollt oder schnee im winter das
heißt mit schlacht geschickt zum teil
von mission so dass man die schicht bord
ist.foto abnimmt und sondern die extrem
wollen wir somit zum beispiel das 115
wodurch der woche überhaupt die sich
methodisch gesehen das geld noch viele
bachelor und extremen zug stand
nur mit viel technik kälte aggregaten
und lüftungssystemen kann der eispalast
überhaupt funktionieren
und doch ist er langsam weg andreas weiß
holt sich rat bei matthias schulze
energie und klima spezialist für
bauprojekte in extremer minus drei grad
luftfeuchtigkeit 100 prozent das wäre
das ideale klima in der eisgrotte sommer
und winter endlich aufträge für was
steht das abschmelzen am schnellsten die
baulichen möglichkeiten sind beschränkt
20 meter tief im gletscher der
herzleistung eigentlichen sinn dass mehr
richtig gemacht die eigentlich
bürgerstube abwickeln
durch das seminar kalte luft die blase
also halte sie produzieren und
dvd-spieler für die nächsten tage wieder
zu erleben
[Musik]
vom jungfraujoch nach interlaken arbeits
und wohnort von urs kessler direktor der
jungfraubahnen seit bald 30 jahren
arbeitet er für das bahnunternehmen seit
acht jahren an der spitze
heute ist ein wichtiger tag
generalversammlung der aktionäre 2000
leute sind angemeldet wollen zahlen
hören erfolge nervosität kennt thomas
kessler nicht seit er das unternehmen
führt gingen die gewinne stetig bergauf
sehr stark wachsen es muss im griff so
wichtig der innovation stehen staunt und
das war vielleicht im kursaal interlaken
sind die geladenen gäste bereits
eingetroffen
lockere atmosphäre beim apéro die
jungfraubahn holding grösste
arbeitgeberin im berner oberland genießt
einen breiten rückhalt in politik und
wirtschaft ebenso urs kessler
dank den besten jahresergebnis aller
zeiten
außerdem ist natürlich noch alte rekord
vom letzten offen der konzern immer die
größte gefahr für und mohn ist ein volk
verrückt und das ist natürlich gewaltige
die sind natürlich jahre sozialwerk
stecken und das ist gerade also mir ist
noch dieselbe meister zielsetzungen
aber es ist extrem hoch nach im jahr
2015 dann der große auftritt von den
kleinaktionären
trotz rekord ja und traum gewinnen ist
orchesters appetit nicht gestellt seine
botschaften sind klar und deutlich
mittelmaß und fertig holt mit zu den
top-destinationen oder grunde million
jung für besucher ist von der vision zu
den ambitiösen richtgröße für die
nächsten arbeiten
das potenzial auf dem tourismusmarkt
insbesondere asiatische markt ist nach
wie vor groß august rückt global ist
jährig heißt nicht anders aus dem
wirtschaftswachstum hinaus partizipieren
für die jungfraubahnen ist das
jungfraujoch die wichtigste
einnahmequelle die cash cow dieser
geldsegen ist für das bahnunternehmen
enorm wichtig er kompensiert das harzige
wintergeschäft auf den lorbeeren
ausruhen will sich urs kessler nicht
mittelmaß ist nicht gefragt
die fahrbahn zwei seilbahnen eine 3
station die eine rechts auf den
männlichen die andere zum eyecatcher
kostenpunkt knapp 300 millionen
unbestritten ist die männlichen bahn sie
ist alt und muss ersetzt werden
anders der eiga express eine
ultraschnelle säubern
in nur 15 minuten auf 200.000 meter
ideal für skifahrer ein massiver
zeitgewinn aber vor allem auch für
jungfraujoch touristen fehlt nur noch
die baubewilligung des bundes doch es
gibt ein sprachen zweifel ob
geschwindigkeit und masse tatsächlich
die richtige strategie ist und genau so
machen wir das projekt mit der großen
investitionen für nachhaltig langfristig
ein folglich fantasie und jungfrau
bauernverband erfolgreich dass sie auch
die ganze hotel leistungsträger battle
handel profitieren
die idylle bewahren oder per express die
zukunft immer alles schneller und
komfortabler
die meisten leute in grindelwald stehen
hinter urs kessler und seinen plänen
nicht so unter kaufmann
ihm wäre es manchmal lieber die zeit
würde stillstehen
auch was die touristen betrifft deutsch
spricht er bei der arbeit kaum noch
[Musik]
eilig
ob es in zukunft wenn die jungfraujoch
touristen mit den express viel zeit
sparen können
die zahnradbahn überhaupt noch braucht
die jungfraubahn sagen ja für die
nächsten 50 jahre sicher otto kaufmann
ist skeptisch
geschäftsmann
diskret der jungs über sex
wer keinen zweifel und skepsis gegen
alles was die jungfraubahnen als
fortschritt anpreisen noch eine fahrt
hoch und eine runter dann hat er es
geschafft
er hat das kochen
[Musik]
vom berner oberland nach südkorea
die hauptstadt seoul südkorea ist eines
der wichtigsten asiatischen länder für
die vermarktung des jungfrau los die
südkoreaner haben geld reichen gerne
europa ist im trend
mitten in der zehn-millionen-stadt
treffen wir urs kessler zusammen mit
seinem lokalen vertreter des verkaufs
reise die taschen voller angebote
das jungfraujoch als verkaufsschlager
nummer 14 mal pro jahr reist orchester
nach asien und vermarktet die
jungfrauregion höchstpersönlich
verkaufen als chefsache
das eben die wichtigsten tricks
natürlich mit denen vor über 20 jahren
aufbau und frauen innovativ kreativ aber
nochmals mit der und redmark tisch und
wales dem markt verlangt seine kunden
sind agenturen die europa reisen
anbieten
urs kessler und jean song klappern die
wichtigsten ab 15 meetings stehen heute
auf dem programm
als urs kessler vor über 20 jahren zum
ersten mal nach korea kam kannte kaum
jemand das jungfraujoch
heute gehört es ins programm vieler
agenturen nicht zuletzt an seinem gespür
für asiatische umgangsformen
schön dass wir uns wiedersehen vielen
dank sieht so aus als sei ich ihre
visitenkarten das ist was eine von die
zehnte ich glaube wir sehen uns zum
ersten mal vielen dank mister lissabon
oder südkorea oder thailand jeder markt
ist komplett anders und ohne 28 jahren
menge ich verstehe ich selber nicht
genau was sie meinen das ist ganz andere
kultur
aber man muss versuchen es bestehe eine
spritzige dort geduld die us kessler mit
sich selber nicht hat nach china taiwan
und thailand ist korea die letzte
station seiner verkaufs reise sieben
tage nonstop bis auf die letzte minute
durchgeplant effizient von a bis z
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und mister an geht es ihnen gut jaja
bietet jetzt noch theater flüge nach
schottland
wie kommt es dass sie nun nach
schottland fliegen ist es wegen golf
golf dann möchte ich ihnen gerne meine
neuigkeiten zeigen golf kann das
jungfraujoch nicht bieten us kessler
zieht alle register seines verkaufs
talents
[Musik]
es ist natürlich sehr schwierig außer
zum teil der sicher aussage heißt das
noch lange nicht dass man rock logisch
also dass sie muss man spüren wäre sie
sagen alle ja wie es eigentlich für
asiatische landesweiten gar nicht geht
ob die agenturen anpassen oder nicht ist
nicht zuletzt auch eine frage des
preises der schweiz europa ihre marke
unermüdlich immer die gleiche story von
morgens bis abends hätte der direktor zu
hause in der schweiz nicht noch andere
wichtigere aufgaben ganz einfach auf den
punkt braucht sagte glock das ist eine
million netto kasse und somit eine
leistungsfähige business und dauer
werbespot auch bei jedem essen die
terroranschläge in europa gaben der
reiselust asiaten einen gewaltigen
dämpfer
umso mehr muss urs kessler ihr vertrauen
zurückgewinnen
die schweiz als sicheres land das
jungfraujoch als traumziel
ich sage immer sehen ist glaube ich bin
hier um ihnen einmal mehr danke zu sagen
vielen dank für ihre unterstützung
vielen dank
[Applaus]
es ist eines der besten und teuersten
restaurants der stadt welches urs
kessler für dieses meeting ausgewählt
hat kein zufall
natürlich eine marke top of europe und
da kommt natürlich vor dazu dass man die
marken seat skoda zusammen mit einer
freundin
conti mit in das neue haus rechte und
die vorräte sind natürlicher und
wichtigste marketing sage nämlich vier
mal anders als alle anderen unternehmen
das ganze für die fernseher
anders als alle anderen
der kampf um die asiatischen touristen
ist härter geworden
die konkurrenz schläft nicht
mit dem vauban projekt und dem einer
express hat urs kessler bei den asiaten
einen weiteren trumpf in der tasche
wettkampf 1 jung für eine sieht sie mit
den zeugnissen akteur außen sie
mitbewerber und auf der anderen seite
zwei bis drei mal engel oder deutschland
natürlich arbeitete schritt wirkung der
anzeige der zukunft aber natürlich auf
wintersport will auch die in südkorea
beim seefest wo mittlerweile zu hoch
sind und nach einer chaotischen worden
abflug zurück in die schweiz zu hause
wartet mit dem jahrhundertprojekt
fahrbahn noch viel arbeit
schon am nächsten morgen verdruss
kessler wieder in seinem büro sein sich
keinen freien tag gönnen
[Musik]
auf dem jungfraujoch ist ein ballett
nudelsuppen angekommen
rund 100 tausend portionen werden pro
jahr aus korea importiert auch eine idee
von urs kessler seit indische und
chinesische köche zur küchenmannschaft
gehören kommen die asiaten noch viel
lieber
es ist einer dieser tage an welchen das
jungfraujoch ausverkauft ist
5000 besucher mehr haben keinen platz
wir sind jetzt den fuß ein foto dapd
mittendrin treffen der martin sache
pächter der vier gletscher restaurants
20 gruppen aus indien sind angemeldet
und 800 personen
alle wollen hessen alles klar wie viele
seiten 31 32 31 er wird sich um uns
kümmern
oben im ersten stock jede halbe stunde
kommt den zug und da kommen solche
gruppen und da muss man in dieser halben
stunde rhythmus ist unser zeitfenster
immer auch für die gruppen
das wissen über die gruppen als auch die
tour manager haben das schon im griff
dass sie wissen mehr zeit dürfte sie
nicht brauchen
sonst funktioniert sind nach nicht essen
wie zu hause im restaurant bollywood
weil touristen aus indien liverpool
curry und tofu statt bratwurst und rösti
haben bekommen sie im indischen
restaurant das was ihnen schmeckt
der kunde ist könig das angebot
hundertprozentig auf die bedürfnisse der
gäste ausgerichtet
vor einer bergkulisse welche die inder
sonst nur aus ihren bollywood filmen
kennen
sofern das wetter mitspielt so schön die
hochalpine gletscher welt auch sein kann
so schnell und brutal kann ein
wetterumschwung alles ändern und die
aussicht vermissen wenn auch nicht
unbedingt die stimmung
bei solchen wetterextremen muss andreas
wies entscheiden ob die touristen
überhaupt noch auf den gletscher dürfen
oder nicht
neben schneefall und kälte sind
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 200
stundenkilometern keine seltenheit
es ist ein ständiger kampf gegen die
naturgewalten gletscherspalten sichern
spazierwege planieren der gletscher als
erlebnispark auch für touristen ist
nicht sicher ist nach montevergine und
100 euro belohnt eigentlich entgegen
doppeltes kritisch und der
stadtvertretung märz geordnet und der
fotos von einem schlag nach unten und
dann habe eine entsprechend wirken und
dass ich noch viele schwierigkeiten dem
hospiz bringen weiß nun nicht mehr
beobachten debatte dort mit
wetterdiensten wollen die g gerichtet
das mit ein halb im scherz der wahl
teilnehmen und sagen jetzt meisterin er
sich gewandelt das handwerk abschnitt
begriffen
egal bei welchem wetter nur schon die
tatsache hier gewesen zu sein auf den
dach europas ist für manche touristen
erlebnis ging
[Musik]
während die einen im besten fall eine
nacht in der region verbringen ziehen
die anderen möglichst schnell weiter auf
ihre reise quer durch europa
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf der kleinen scheidegg treffen wir
otto kaufmann vorbereitungen für seine
letzte fahrt runter nach grindelwald
innerlich hat er mit der bahn schon
längst abgeschlossen
auch wenn man hier mit zusammen und
haben wir vollkommen legal ist von ihm
nicht sieht
und der kaufmann erledigt seinen job wie
immer auch am letzten tag aussprachen
zwischen ihm und urs kessler brachten
keine lösung verhärtete die fronten
aber sie folgt brasilien ihr charakter
wie gewohnt war das ist schlimm stammt
das wahlfach seither hundes werden und
dabei keine alternativen links oder
rechts einfach dass ich der linie und da
gibt es nichts zu rütteln
und das hat mir im moment akzeptieren so
otto kaufmann steht nicht gerne im
mittelpunkt darum verzichtete er auch
auf ein abschiedsfest mit seinen
kollegen
einfach die uniform an den bügel und
schluss abgeben kann er sie noch später
[Musik]
so
das war es noch vorher
[Musik]
im moment dreht sich bei otto kaufmann
alles nur noch um den express der ihm
und seiner frau die idylle auf seinem
flecken land zerstören
die beiden haben sich darum einen anwalt
genommen
der eigner express würde den wert ihres
hauses massiv verringern ersichtlich
dass die londoner us produktionen
mehreren millionen 68 ist also wie
sollen das motiv 100 millionen fr
man muss so schafft ist exzessives das
team erst mehr war zweite musik lied ins
stunden tour mitmachen ich will jetzt
wieder langsam das grundeigentum nicht
mehr respektiert
das haben wir jetzt dran eine 20
leichten moneycab ist vor bundesgericht
dass das aber hat er sich zwar cross
das kostet dann gefühl und das ist auch
richtig so erschien nörvenich aus köln
sagt es gibt keine bombe bombe ein
erweitertes akzeptiere oder mit der
enteignung würde heißen die überfahrt
rechte erzwingen mit einer minimalen
entschädigung als letztes rechtliches
mittel
[Musik]
hier auf seiner halb in der nähe der
kleinen scheidegg will otto kaufmann
seinen inneren frieden wiederfinden
beim käsen weit weg von streitereien und
anwälten
[Musik]
seit us kessler aus asien zurück ist
beschäftigen die einsprachen gegen das
vauban projekt rund um die uhr erfährt
von aussprache zu aussprach wir gegner
persönlich überzeugen
einer seiner härtesten brocken ist otto
kaufmann wilhelm widersprach wird im
letzten jahr stark wird nur 120 dezember
20 15 ps sparens längeres gespräch
geführt ich habe immer versucht und alle
verweigerten zeltplatz und das ist eben
diesen ehemaliger mitarbeiter über 40
jahren bedingungen für bahnen
urs kessler rennt langsam die zeit davon
er möchte möglichst bald die
baubewilligung bekommen und dann
loslegen
neben otto kaufmann gibt es noch weitere
einsprachen unter anderem von pro natura
und landschaftsschutz schweiz
[Musik]
um diese einsprache abzuwenden hat urs
kessler der landschaftsschützer raimund
rodewald zu einer persönlichen
aussprache eingeladen
gleich hier vor ort um sich ein bild zu
machen
[Musik]
umweltverbände und auch andere kritiker
sind der meinung der einer express würde
wie eine wäscheleine das spielt der
eigernordwand massiv stören muss kessler
will diesen vorwurf nicht gelten lassen
und dezember das da geht es nach einer
guten apple blick der planer das ganze
eigentlich hier integriert ist also hier
und mit den eigenen genau eigentlich nur
mal nicht ob sie nach etikette möchte
nicht über ganz viele männer aber dass
diese lokalen sauber ja und das war
natürliche quellen hat und wie es dreht
sie vorinformiert von der durchschnitt
von algen oder und ohne portal stellt
wenn man das einfach da nicht die op
wäre wenn das rennen das praktisch nie
absolut verständnis so sieht
perspektiven und sie hat eine acht
varianten womöglich schlussendlich so
beurteilt wurde dass das acronis
landschaftlich die beste und roma ist
oft hier fokussiert und es ist klar es
ist nix gebiet aber bei mir kann man
bauen damit unsichtbar machen soll jetzt
drängen jetzt ganz wunderbar einfach das
ist doch wirklich das spektakuläre
touristischen wirkt oder wenn wir
einfach die über nachrichten verstehen
du hast dort die bahn
und da stellt auch für europa geht
menschen sondern weltweit zu unterhalten
und dann ist auch einfach nie bewegt und
permanent deutschland stabil dienen die
marsch das sind diese erst problems ist
optimiert
aber du hast einfach da eine
überlagerung wo du einfach das sind
jetzt die touristen oder dürfe
katapultiert werden
fazit für mich einfach dass das projekt
monat ein punkt wo es einfach auch die
top of europe qualität vorsicht
landschaft war so prüft die vermutlich
noch mal überlegen wir haben mit
revanche höhere reduktion mit der
standort verschiebung accent zwei masten
sind relativ exponiert halt in der
landschaft wir haben heute einfach nur
mal größere schon ich vor dem
letztendlich auch unesco welterbe gebiet
erreichen
es kann auf der inter sieht die
wirtschaftliche interesse ist natürlich
sehr wichtig sie und auf der andern
seite die landschaftliche und ich glaube
das ziel muss im dialog die bestmögliche
lösung zu finden und bis mittags
grossmehrheitlich immer gefunden
bonn ist tempeh internist natürlich wenn
wir wirtschaftlich sinnvolle projekt
durch verhinderungs prinzip trotz
klärung noch keine einigung
es wird noch mehr verhandlungen noch
mehr gutachten brauchen us kesslers
kampf für ein jahrhundertprojekt ist
noch lange nicht ausgestanden
[Musik]
etwas weiter unten die alle von otto
kaufmann
die hütte geschlossen die alp
[Applaus]
[Musik]
otto kaufmanns letzter arbeitstag bei
der bahn liegt schon ein paar wochen
zurück
eigentlich hätte er längst hier sein
wollen
doch es kam alles anders sein arm in der
schlinge verheißt nichts gutes
statt auf der alb war otto kaufmann acht
tage im spital
kurz bevor die alb saison beginnen
sollte ist es passiert
[Musik]
die maschinen gehen aus dem land die
kredite zwischen 17 erfolg sie bildung
lagen zum teil leicht funktional aber ob
es um ihren besuchern dass ich das noch
machen die alt ist für otto und chris
kaufmann wie ein zweites zuhause im
sommer als alt käserei im winter als
scheiber der unfall hat ihre pläne für
diesen sommer total auf den kopf
gestellt
im moment kann otto kaufmann fast nichts
tun außer zuschauen
gleichzeitig beschäftigt die beiden
immer noch der streit mit den
jungfraubahnen wegen dem einer express
mit der entschädigung die ihnen
angeboten wurde sind sie nicht
einverstanden
vom baby das mit kaká bezahlen ist mir
das so eine sache also weniger will
wiederkommen wenn wir es am ende kein
entscheid machen was mir machen ob man
es ja gar nicht einige oder weniger das
ist doch klar dass man rasch zum open in
skoda zum teil wahrscheinlich anschluss
verlieren aber meinem opa btc mit
einfach sagen schnell und meist ja und
was jetzt der 100 mann ist ein lila
helfen also übernehmen auch sagen
community vertreten
[Musik]
auf dem jungfraujoch erwartet andreas
wies und seine männer ein strenger tag
kann heute morgen
jetzt waren am morgen war sicher die
wahl begriff stellen nur tribüne fertig
zu machen was zu diesem thema lädt wort
übrig für treppen so als ob andreas wie
es nicht schon so alle hände voll zu tun
hätte ist für heute ein sport event auf
dem gletscher angesagt schon etliche
stars ließen sich in den letzten jahren
für werbezwecke einspannen
so auch roger federer und lindsay vonn
oder schwingerkönig kilian wenger
dieses jahr ist es fast ball andreas
beez und seine helfer hatten auf dem
gletscher in kürzester zeit ein
basketball feld aufgestellt
was enkeln organ übersichtlichen
abwechslung sorgen oeser verteidigte
unters messer laufen und dann wenn man
alles tipptopp es auch dort hat den euro
geschätzt dass wir doch von diesem seo
wird sehr geschätzt was man da machen
kaum von ihm geredet ist er auch schon
da rund 100 journalisten aus aller welt
sind eingeladen
der marketing-profi kessler weiß man
punkten kann
ziel ist natürlich wie jeder journalist
einen artikel schreibt
für sie soll wie man sie kaum mit
anderen events zum teil der haben wir
das web marketing meist gar nicht zahlen
das ist ein unglaublicher wert generiert
aber es ist verrückt
heute zum normalen auch der motor sie
muss musik ordentlich es auch machen und
das ist aber so ein event motto vier mal
anders als alle anderen
der star des events kommt wie es sich
für einen star gehört per helikopter
so kommen
stoppen
es ist der franzose tony parker
gefeierter nba spieler in amerika einer
der erfolgreichsten europäischen
basketballer aller zeiten
foto shooting mit star und sponsoren als
gegner steht eine schweizer basketball
auswahl bereit
urs kessler überlässt nichts dem zufall
übernimmt selbst die regie die kameras
bereit und los team tony parker gegen
die schweiz in der dünnen luft auf 3000
meter ist das tempo eher gemächlich das
orchester für dieses jahr basketball
ausgewählt hat ist kein zufall
natürlich
ob marketing gag oder geniestreich was
zählt ist nur der erfolg die hohen gagen
und enormen kosten für den technischen
aufwand seien verglichen mit dem
werbeeffekt nebensächlich genau so
nebensächlich wie das resultat des
spiels urs kessler und die sponsoren
genießen ihren auftritt mit den star
[Musik]
noch ein paar interviews dann wird alles
wieder abgebaut
der gletscher ist wieder gletscher und
urs kessler wieder zurück im
tagesgeschäft
ziel ist nach wie vor so schnell wie
möglich die sprache sondern im sinn für
komik sprache und es war einiges
leichter vergleichbar bietet das linde
laden arbeitsbühnen und schlecht gefühlt
[Musik]
so schnell er gekommen ist so schnell
ist er wieder weg
tony parker der star des tages schon
morgen wird sein foto in den zeitungen
zu sehen sein
beim korbwurf vor der beeindruckenden
bergkulisse des jungfrau york
[Musik]
von all dem jubel und trubel auf dem
joch ist unten in grindelwald nichts zu
spüren
[Musik]
zurück von der alb treffen wir otto und
chris kaufmann zu hause im garten der
gips ist weg foto kaufmann kann sich
wieder etwas nützlich machen auch wenn
das für ihn keine wirkliche arbeit ist
[Musik]
liegen
da war ich glaube sie haben dann immer
praktisch nie mit dem land
[Musik]
ihr kampf gegen den bau des einer
express ist noch nicht ausgestanden
urs kessler bot ihnen die maximale
entschädigungssumme für private
landbesitzer lehnen sie ab bekommen sie
nur das gesetzliche minimum annehmen
oder ablehnen
sie lehnten ab aus sturheit mir ist
keine tricks kaputter hätte das geld ist
in dem scout es geht und wo ministerien
entschieden aber hey du etwas mehr welt
und kosten akzeptiert entscheidet sich
kurz mehr noch er gar nicht nutzt und
jetzt mit ihr drauf und regnen
machen sie also stress längsten passiert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sowohl der impreza klar ist der name
marcel krause seligen trend nicht mehr
den preis einigen
das rad der zeit anhalten oder sich per
express in die touristische zukunft
katapultieren
der entscheid liegt nun beim bundesamt
für verkehr wegweisend für die ganze
jungfrau region
[Musik]